the first thing you're going to do is I
can all fold open up and do the same
thing on the other side
[Applause]
I'm going to pick two sides of the
square and fold it as close to the
center as you'd like same on the other
side try to keep it equal
and then you're going to fold this top
part down
I like to crease a little bit here just
make the next fold easier you're going
to push these corners in by popping the
top part out and then just folding down
next you're going to take these
triangles pull them down to make the
whole shape look kind of like a house
and crease the top crease across the top
pull up and then pull at the bottom up
pleat the top brain do another pocket
fold on the bottom so I pre-crease these
and push these corners in
let's make the prong small you want to
fold from the side in till the edges
match same thing on this side and you're
going to pull the left side out and
flatten it back out on this right corner
you want to fold it over so you have a
flat edge and to make the prongs shorter
precrease
and then tuck them in
the last fold is holding at the corner
of the prong here and then making a
small triangle with a cockpit on this
side plenty of oaken